normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government ladies
and gentlemen I give you predictive
programming hey who wants to read those
words I don't want to say it out loud it
says are you are you ready everybody
Civil War what is this official trailer
HD a24 the new movie that is coming out
in 2024 starring Kirsten Dunst and many
others is a movie about 19 states
seceding from the Union
a civil war erupting and the the Western
forces of California and Texas are
attacking their way through the US to
make their way to DC for some reason we
don't know the exact story all I know is
the premise based on the trailer sounds
completely ridiculous Texas and
California will never unite there would
not be a Civil War in which those two
states are unified because there are
states between them however they do
mention 19 states seceded in the trailer
so it could be that Texas and California
are part of the secession but the reason
it's called the Western force of Texas
and California is because they're the
two largest states in the seceding group
I don't understand why they would team
up at all I wonder what the story is
going to be but how is there a civil war
movie that they did not consult the
timcast crew on that's what I want to
know I feel like this should have been
like where they focus on I got a feeling
that they're not going to involve
foreign countries coming in and like cuz
what would happen in a real Civil War is
the CCP would be heavily involved
funding the war LS of chines weapons
Andes and and the Russians and the
Iranians and the
syrians it be a bit of a mess yeah it'll
be the Israeli government as well
especially and they would say would be
everywhere yeah they would call it
California but it ain't California doing
the weapon same do right now it would be
California and the Chinese would go to
them and they'd say we will give you
anything you want and we don't care what
happens afterwards and we will guarantee
your Independence after you win that's
what they'll tell them right right yes
yes yes they're saying just fight each
other just rip your country to shreds
that's it but a lot of people are
tweeting out predictive programming the
idea of predictive programming is that
powerful Elites government agents or
whatever condition the public through
mass media to encourage certain
behaviors in the event of a certain
circumstance so a simple a simple idea
would be let's say Civil War breaks out
nobody knows what it's going to look
like they want to create image of what a
civil war would look like before it
happens so that your behaviors will be
will fall into a certain Camp so uh some
ways to explain this right people don't
know what gunshots sound like because
they only hear guns for movies it's not
what gun sounds like every time someone
raises a gun in a movie The Hammer
clicks the gun which makes
literally no sense but because they're
and I don't believe that this is to
condition you it's because they're
trying to make you know the guns coming
but you'll always see in movies like
Indiana Jones for instance the new one
everybody raises guns to him and you
hear all the guns cocking like dude the
guns are already cocked round is already
chambered they're raising the gun there
would be no sound but for dramatic
effect so imagine it this way Civil War
breaks out everyone does a bunch of
random things you make a movie Civil War
breaks out and water is poisoned don't
drive Teslas a big component of the film
then what happens is this idea SE
everyone's mind from watching a movie
that's probably wrong Civil War breaks
out everyone says better stay away from
Teslas that's the idea of predictive
programming I don't believe that's the
case you know I I me it's possible I
guess I think the reality is there have
been numerous articles numerous
statements from academics talking about
the possibility of a civil war there
have been numerous polls where people
say they want a civil war there have
been members of Congress calling for a
national divorce and some dude goes this
would be a great movie and he writes it
all down goes to an investor and says
let's make this movie yeah there's many
what we find was really behind the movie
he like are you are you Bank rolling
this are you point for the past seven
years was I can make you doing theed
program I see so we were we were
actually talking about this idea
yesterday I just posted the clip on my
uh Twitter at lukee are change uh
describing what I was uh talking about
when it comes to predictive programming
because I do believe that there are
actual incidences where this happened 24
and torture is one of them I mentioned
it yesterday we also saw the buildup to
the Iraq War have a lot of a lot of
popular media that went along with it
that essentially drove the American
people to believe that their lives were
in danger unless we fought the terrorist
over there and not over here so when you
look at the intelligence agencies and
their larger influence on pop culture on
media and entertainment this has this
has been something that they've been
influencing for many decades now a lot
of people bring up um a mocking bird a
lot of people bring up the the
commission hearings that were happening
within Congress that exposed the
infiltration of the corporate media by
the intelligence agencies and if you're
at the Intel agencies what better way to
to get away with these larger ideas than
to kind of make people acques to them
through uh entertainment through
subconscious subliminal messaging in
films in movies I think this is why we
are seeing such racial division tones
almost in every form of entertainment
now I think it's also important to note
that right before the Ukrainian War
there was an extreme amount of Russian
propaganda we saw the corporate deep
State kind of media all in unison say
Russia Russia Russia hacked this
election and as we know none of that was
actually true but but the the Russian
Boogeyman was built up and now we are in
a proxy war with Russia using Ukraine as
essentially our larger kind of forces on
the ground to do the fighting for us and
sacrific their lives for this larger
neoconservative objective so I I do
believe predictive programming is true I
do believe it has been used there's a
lot of different ways to interpret it um
a lot of people will extrapolate
whatever little things they want to
extrapolate but I think it's clear Intel
agencies control the media the media
does send out particular messaging that
does actually happen you you you think
there's a strong possibility that
they're conditioning us to prepare for a
Civil War uh now as far as the whole
Civil War context again you can't really
say because it's more clear after the
fact so well real quick sorry to
interrupt but I just
it could be that they're trying to
condition people to not want Civil War
yeah it it's also impossible to figure
figure it out until after everything
happens because then you kind of put all
the pieces together uh especially when
it came to justifying torture in America
when it came to the the larger
entertainment entertainment series that
also had Intel influences that were
excusing torture by the Intel agencies
that's a clear example of them then us
finding out through Snowden and weile
leaks that yes they were actually
torturing and trying to excuse it
through uh media forms of entertainment
so couple years down the line if there's
a civil war we could say yes this was
the kind of predictive programming when
the whole Russia gate collusion stuff
was happening no one kind of foresaw hey
this is going to lead us to be in a kind
of proxy war with Russia now that we are
I think it's fair to say that that all
the stuff that we were hearing about
Russia being the boogeyman laid the
groundwork for us now being in this
proxy war so so this is how it works
we're going to know definitively later
down the line we know we can't know now
we can't tell now the reason why they
were trying to claim that Trump was a
Russian spy is because we were supposed
to be at war with Russia in Ukraine in
2014 and 15 into 2016 or I should just
say 2017 because Obama leaves everything
freezes the escalation on the on the
Eastern front of Ukraine sort of stopped
Donald Trump gets in he says I don't
want war and then all of a sudden the
Ukrainian stuff froze I was in Ukraine
when this stuff was all started I was
there at the beginning of the year on
Myan protests I I got told go and
actually see the statue that was toppled
fragments of of Lennon's head on the
ground and then uh Molotov cocktails I
ended up leaving around then it
escalated from there and the remaining
Vice C actually went to yanukovich's
house the former president who was
ousted and fled the country then Trump
gets elected everything stops and if
Hillary would have became president
there was a very high likelihood that
there would have been war with Russia
John McCain like L 100% yeah yeah John
McCain I mean it also depends on a lot
of different factors China also plays a
role in this as well so does Iran so
does Saudi Arabia uh but but we have to
understand Lindsey Graham and John mcain
were in Ukraine during the mine
Revolution which was influenced by the
intelligence agencies that also helped
spur it on and help move Ukraine away
from the Russian influence towards the
more NATO Western influence they were
there on the ground saying yes we have
to fight the Russians we have to kick
out the Russians we have to have NATO
here inside of Ukraine all the way back
in
2014 and they were banking the military
industrial complex the central banks
banksters the controllers were banking
on a larger conflict if Trump wasn't
elected and uh Trump still did some
things he did send lethal weapons to
Ukraine but his foreign policy
definitely wasn't as aggressive as
Hillary Clinton's would have been as
she's a total bloodthirsty Warhawk that
literally celebrates the torture and
death of individuals and cheers and
laughs about it I was thinking as you
were talking that came yeah we saw died
that KFI that was so crazy she laughed
the camera was on knif just being
stabbed into
his what we're doing is predictive
programming as well it's just not as
subtle as putting it in a movie We're
actually just projecting what we think
is going to happen and that in a way is
prepping people for maybe believing okay
I I'll get ready for what you think is
going to happen so we that's a big
responsibility and Luke I'm really glad
you brought up that show 24 yes Jack
Bower it was ke for Sutherland it was in
2003 right after world or uh SE setember
11th uh right after the towers came down
uh and it was like he was an anti he was
like fighting terrorists and he was just
such a good guy and there was a about to
go off in New York City and they needed
to torture someone to save everyone in
New York City and then right after that
they're like oh we're torturing people
it's okay because we want to save people
from getting nuked meanwhile they were
torturing goat herders that literally
were sleeping with someone's cousin that
they didn't like and The Afghani
neighbor snitched on them said that
they're Taliban and then they were sent
to Egypt and literally had their
children I can't even say this but hurt
in unspeakable Ways by CIA officials
that were torturing them in front of the
the goat hurters there for freak's sakes
that is it's just mindboggling to to to
see the level of just how Sinister this
is and and the the things behind the
scenes that actually do happen that that
they use to justify this kind of
criminality and Insanity we used to
watch 24 cuz you guys Bush adman loves
24 so I have fun I'll give a short
version of his story is don't kick me
off from ever coming back to cast I have
to tell tell you this so I once spent
the day with Carl Rove and his favorite
show was 24 get out true story I don't
care yeah I know what do you like about
it I I think all the things tort
torturing you know you know going after
we didn't get into a lot I don't we get
a lot of detail this has been many years
ago it was like the show is 24 is all
about 20 every episode there was 24
hours until some horrible thing epis he
was always in a rush he was always a
Race Against Time no it was it was a
real time wasn't it like 24 was the
that's right an hour 10 what was bizarre
to me is I would have thought someone
like Carl Ro who's been in the places
that he's been and lived the life that
he's lived he would think like this
Show's stupid it's so fake it's so
whatever but he was like no this is a
great show I watch every single House of
Cards did that too man house of cards
made us think that it's okay for
politicians to be corrupt like it's like
yo it's just how it is look how Charming
Kevin spacy is in this too it's okay he
smiles the Pentagon literally hires
Hollywood producers and writers to write
scripts for them about events that they
then go to the American people and say
was truth they hired Jeremy brookheimer
to do the whole Jessica Lynch story if
you remember that story that was an
insane large scop on the American people
to push the Iraq War to make everyone
stand for this very strong independent
woman that stood up and fought to the
last Iraqi she stood up on a Gunner and
took them all down when in reality she
was cing in fear the Iraqis took her to
a hospital and said hey America can you
please pick her up America send in tanks
blew up the hospital took her out and
then the CIA and Jerry brookheimer ran
with a story saying this Brave woman was
saved by American Heroes after she
fought killing the last Iraqi which was
all bull I know what the predictive
programming is the ma the main character
the protagonist what is their job save
the world no they're a journalist oh
gross they're journalists and so already
the trailer narrative is civil war is
bad journalists are good gross here we
go the media is distrusted for years
people have hated the media Kirsten
Dunst plays a journalist and she's she
has this line it's actually a good line
she says every time I came back from a
war I thought I was sending home a
warning and I'm like I really like that
she was saying the warning was don't do
this here
and I think the last time that maybe the
last time that happened was Vietnam I
can't think of the journalist name I'd
like to name right now from Vietnam that
came back with some of those warnings
but U I wish a could name this is a good
I like the word Wars and the word
warning uh yeah don't do it here look
what happened in Ukraine look what's
happening in Ukraine that's what happens
when War happens destroyed I can't
believe these freaking lunatics that
were out there speaking screaming from
their rooftops that Ukraine could win
that war no they were lying they knew
they werey don't know anything about
anything and I remember early on I was
like no that's there's no way this is
not going to
happen country to get horror after the
fall of Soviet Union and they're going
to beat Russia come one of the most
corrupted countries in the world yeah
even if they won even if that it would
be so devastating was possible it was
never possible and I had I remember
having this conversation with people
like you just talk CU you love like I
don't like Putin it like you can look at
facts and just say this country is going
to get annihilated over time and that's
what's happening they' they've killed
off a generation of men in Ukraine this
is offensive somebody in the chat said
Alex Garland is a genius Tim didn't pass
the 11th grade that is shockingly
offensive I didn't pass the ninth grade
Who's Alex I can't believe you beat me I
want to say I'm around 10th grade I
dropped out of high school oh nice stop
showing off you guys I was home I can
actually top Tim on this I was
homeschooled and I dropped out of home
school thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time